you do you play any catches or any of
those games
thank god thank god
thank god good choice you're a real one
yeah yeah
you know you don't need to fall into
that hellhole what's your uh what's your
addiction if you have one that he saw
what are you what are you my addiction
yeah let me think other than adidas
okay
that's not an addiction that's a
lifestyle
a strip that's stripped i need a squat
see my my costume has adidas lines in it
does it really
or anything that you're super addicted
to super addicted to let me think it's
not gotcha it's a win streaming
yeah i'm addicted to streaming of course
right i'm a full-time streamer so yes
but um
right now i'm addicted to far cry
okay which one the new one yeah
um i'm right now i'm playing far cry 5.
oh are you going through them all yeah
oh okay okay i heard they get like worse
and worse as they go on you know i heard
like spoilers i don't know i don't know
i've only played
three i think
yeah was that the good one
three is the good one i enjoyed it i i
enjoy playing three
what's your favorite far cry so far um
i've only played five i just started i
just started oh oh okay oh oh you've
already played far cry 5. yeah
she's already invited i thought she
played like [ __ ] right once again yeah
yeah that's what i thought
[Applause]
oh no like i've just i've just i just
know the one with like gus that's the
new one six okay so oh that's the dust
frame that's frank he's the meme of we
are not the same i can't i can't oh that
guy yeah
have you ever
so you've been playing far cry and then
you also we played minecraft
oh yeah i have my own server i just
started
playing with my friends well thank you
for telling me on my server um
sorry for that
top 10 anime betrayals
i was invisible to be fair i will you
know i'll give you the benefit of the
doubt
and then you went and killed yourself
anyway like two minutes later so it was
okay i think it was all right i think i
think it was revenge was well served
yeah by yourself
but uh
minecraft is pretty fun i enjoy
minecraft joey's a minecraft expert i'm
not he is he's an expert i'm not he's an
expert i just tried to get you into it
he's an expert so i opened the door for
you so you've never played minecraft
before you mostly started streaming
minecraft no yeah yeah i still don't i
really want to get into it but the first
time he played minecraft was with me
yeah the old studio oh yeah are you
liking my how many times you played
minecraft now how many
um i just started um i'm just a beginner
i don't know it's really overwhelming
right yeah there's so much to do
is it fun
it's a simple question can i not ask it
joey
i don't know it's just like
it's the most
i decided
i've never played it before okay i want
mining crafting
the game depends if it is fun or not it
depends what you'd like to do luckily
minecraft is varied so you can do what
you want now i on the server on the
vshojo server which i played on yeah uh
they were just all building things i
didn't want to build things like one of
those houses yeah i wanted i wanted to
go and like do the raids because there's
like i want to do a i want to have a
goal that's that's the biggest yeah well
there's like there's like bosses and
raids in the in this modded one yeah so
i wanted to just go and explore and kill
things and level up that's the good
thing about minecraft you can do
anything you can do whatever you want
man your imagination is the limit you
can code in minecraft can you actually
yeah there's redstone and you can code
with it yeah there's a dude who made a
fully functioning computer in minecraft
using redstone yeah yeah they made
pokemon as well
they programmed pokemon into the game
they made a working cell phone drink but
i think it was a promotion with um 18 t
or something something like that yeah at
least one of their phones works because
normally that's where they're like they
they
they code i think it was something like
they coded it into the game so that when
you put on a webcam right the blocks
according to the webcam like pixels
but it's all pretty it's a very powerful
game yeah it's really cool it's
something like that it's pretty fun when
you get into it and you start to
understand a bit more about the game it
gets more fun i think you'll enjoy
yeah and then if you get bored just go
creative mode and just do whatever the
[ __ ] you're doing it's a camera thing
with with mods does that work with marge
[Music]
i don't know if that's a publicly
available mod it might have been like a
one-off it might have been a one-off
thing yeah yeah i think was it captain
sparkles something like that yeah it's
one of the big minecraft youtubers i
feel sad that i missed the minecraft
boom in some ways it'll come back i mean
it's kind of booming it never stops
it had like we missed
now we're booming with content before it
used to be just songs and [ __ ] and that
was so funny those songs all the
animations yeah yeah i love those
terrible i mean i feel like every time
it dies it comes back it comes back even
stronger and yeah like i i feel like
goku yeah
oh my [ __ ] god joey
all right i filled my anime quarter for
the episode uh let's move on joey's
mentioned anime
proving like that i am the anime man
yeah you know every song just come back
you're all right
yeah are you are you a big anime fan um
yeah i think i am i think you think you
are um
the title of it is enough i haven't
eaten one i i have actually named every
animal he's like ascended now
the title alone scares people exactly
what kind of anime do you like what are
you into um i i grew up with dragon ball
of course i love goku
um
i can do gohan's voice oh really yeah
barely dead gohan
so to explain this this is the japanese
voice again
how did you get
the western gohan sounds very different
what made you want to learn this skill
i didn't learn it um some viewer told me
that i sound like i'm barely dead gohan
just go for it i mean yeah you're good
at it it sounds pretty smart
i'm a pro at barely dead go handcuff you
almost kind of sound like barely dead
goku as well oh yeah yeah because it's
pretty much the same voice
goku and the japanese dub do sound very
very similar yeah i mean they are
farther i don't know i don't know it
makes sense i don't know the difference
what of gohan and goku yeah gohan's like
gohan's basically that
i don't know anything about dragon ball
who is like
do you hear the difference
it's a very shuttle difference they're
only dragon ball fans
to tell you the difference corporate
needs to find a difference between these
two sounds between dying gohan and dying
let's just rewind back a bit you said
you don't know dragon ball no what
what wait what do you mean have you ever
watched or really never watched it or
read it played it so you only know it
through osmosis yeah i know that they do
they are can we hand my heart
oh my god
i think i think my dad might know more
about dragon ball than you do i know the
spirit bomb yeah that's i know the
hajjuk in an architecture
i've never felt such a bigger generation
gap than than now almost what happened
okay
so like
so like how many of like the side
characters and like their laws do you
know or anything like that you know
vegeta right i know vegeta i know
piccolo do you know who vegeta marries
bulma yeah okay that's just from like
people on twitter like role playing it
and i'm like i'm like what the [ __ ] is
this and do you know what their kid's
name is
sanjuro
luffy
luffy's
movie
what's the kid called trunks i know
trunks yeah i didn't know that was his
kid yeah i know trunks because there's a
guy who wanted to look like trunks and
he like dresses up and i saw that video
guy like 70k on himself yeah he looks
like have you seen this video it's a guy
who wants to look like trunks in the us
i think yeah and then he like he does
look like trunks to be fair but to be
fair like he likes plastic surgery yeah
so yeah he gets like plastic surgery and
he also like colors his hair purple it's
really bizarre but he's also like jacked
yeah i mean whatever makes you happy
yeah so he like looks like a real life
trunks it's pretty cool i mean he seems
like he's killing it yeah
as long as you're not hurting anyone as
long as you're happy imagine boo
oh yeah
that would have been really embarrassing
if i got that wrong um do you know the
villain that comes before martian um yes
um
i'm just i'm just realizing every
[ __ ] dragon ball reference i've made
during the last two years you've just
smiled no no no no no no no no no no
it's not an entirely no no our
friendship is based on your life
goku
listen drip goku has had nothing to do
with goku is probably like oh yeah i
love that episode where he puts on the
supreme
i love i love it when he puts on the
supreme jacket
ever
are you aware of this meme the the drip
goku meme oh yeah okay
i actually have the jacket i didn't
bring it with me today though
unfortunately i saw it on twitter oh
yeah i should have brought it with you
you could have been dressed i i wanted
to drift oh my god
um
uh i know the villain name i know him
the the one who looks like a budget
mewtwo
um
i think he's talking about freeze a
freezer that's it
he looks like a bunch of mewtwo
i'm pretty sure frieza came before me
did he
of course which one's frieza fr freezer
is budget mewtwo
okay right but frieza definitely came
before mewtwo
so mewtwo is the budget frieza oh [ __ ]
you're wrong
i [ __ ] up see see i i understand
dragon ball references because i've been
in the otaku animation yeah yeah where i
understand dragon ball reference and i'm
like
you can't like name like any story
portion or anything like that sometimes
i'll make a joke being like oh my god
this is so long it's like a dragon ball
fights
vegeta and goku were fighting for like
20 episodes that that did happen yeah
exactly right c yeah it's easy enough to
figure out what dragon ball fans like to
be
that's probably one of the shorter
fights it's like if you if you let me go
in the zoo i'm sure i could fit in with
the monkeys after 20 minutes of watching
oh yeah it's like that
what do you use that
i just i'm sorry i just wanted to take a
jammer dragon ball just to assimilate
getting off dragon ball though is there
any other animes that you like as well
of course
so you love fortnite
why did you say yes to that
[ __ ] hilarious and i love it
i think what happened is he saw where
boruto was going and he's just like i've
lost all hopes for this franchise and i
have to revive himself hey to be fair
watching him do like the signs i don't
know what they're called uh the jutsus
the jutsus and then just pull out a gun
there's something really funny about
that i think i think we call that
russian gun
yeah
just did the hand thing and whipped out
an ak and it's like what the [ __ ] and
then the fortnite
i think you were seeing sasuke do the
fortnite dance that just really like
killed my [ __ ] childhood that that's
the it wasn't the gun it was the
fortnight dance and i'm just like
yeah it's just kakashi flossing because
it's only a one amount of time before we
get tanjiro doing it
and i'm just like this is this this is
what itachi died for this is just just
like [ __ ] sasuke doing the fortnite
dance i'm just
what are the animes you're into it seems
like you're into like the classics yeah
the classic
yeah i mean the classic ones and um of
course um
that's how you fit in japan i i've
realized if i want to fit in with any
japanese person
yeah
i love kimono
i know that i know that i love that one
yes i too know why
it's like himetsu one piece and jojo if
you say those yeah more so kimetsu and
one piece i'd say jojo sometimes people
are like what's that yeah jojo is like a
specific demographic whereas kimetz is
just everyone every single even if
they're like eighty ninety years old
they they know come on they've watched
it yeah and jiu jitsu weirdly now
actually yeah did you see kaisen is and
pretty popular yeah weirdly so yeah did
you like jesus christ i loved it i
thought it was so good i thought it was
like just okay i don't know oh my god
here it is with joey
joey's like i don't know i'm too popular
it's not even that it's like i thought
um i'm on joey's side with it um
it was like i i thought it had
everything that i thought i was going to
like but then the end result was just
kind of like what underwhelming i don't
know where where before we before we
start comparing what did you think of
demon slayer then i thought the message
was good by the way do you think it's on
the same level i think i think he
mentors better than jesus guys
personally i'm holding my title
do you agree yeah what did you think was
not good about jiu jitsu it's too
complicated
oh it wasn't even though
what was your video i understood
everything tell me your argument i don't
know it's just it just kind of had every
trope that we've already seen you but
just deal with slayer that's literally
yeah yeah i felt like you did the tropes
the best that's what made it stand out
is that it took the tropes and it did
some other things that were interesting
as well and it just did it better i'm
not saying it was a bad shot i enjoyed
the show i just don't think it's as good
as people say it is i think it's i think
it deserves the hype way more than
dean's leg watching jiu jitsu
and then watching something like my hero
academia it's it's like going from a
five to go from a five course meal to
like a plane cracker oh dude
i would watch jutsu over my hero any day
to be honest do you like my hair academy
um better than jujutsu
oh really see the the difference you
know i really regret inviting you right
now
today
we can't agree on anything i didn't
think i'd get passionate about anime
today because it's because it's trash
taste but i'm getting passionate about
stanley today
this is like the it's fortnite overrated
conversation this is literally that this
is literally that conversation like
we're talking about our anime overrate
[ __ ] hell i hate my life did you
watch arcane
no i don't know that watch our kids oh
thank god okay finally you know it's so
good it's so good it's so good please
watch it please watch it but we all
agree that one piece is the best right
yes i haven't watched it yes
um
i know how far did you get this is like
when my mom asked me if i studied
sanji joined and that's the end of my
journey
hell yeah we're on the same page that's
not even the epilogue i mean yeah that's
not even prologue i've read zero
chapters
but you're going to right i am going to
yeah again i've only watched the four
kids uh version that's i'm sorry and
again i think i've mentioned it before
like the the stuff i really tell me when
you you start reading it and i will also
like re-read from where i am yeah so
that we can all be up to speed okay i
always get curious do you watch like and
play stuff that your stream basically
recommends because i noticed
working working in the field i guess you
know some of the recommendations some of
the recommendations i get of what to
watch and play basically just come from
my audience
so i'm wondering if is that how you guys
not just to case on but is that how you
guys basically choose what media to
consume nowadays as well
um
but
i i say mostly yes yeah yeah i don't get
any informations from other friends
they're just
they never leave home they don't know
anything they don't watch tv
are they in prison
for anything like that
i mean i guess you've got to like follow
your audience to some capacity right
just because you know you are you are i
guess performing quote unquote too
though when you're on stream do you get
a lot of free time because we've had uh
we've had previous videos on before
she's a streamer of course she doesn't
hurt i do nothing
you sounded so happy about that that's
not so sad
otaku dream right yeah just doing
nothing let's do nothing